I'm sorry I just missed Anthony do you
think Nina picks on him I think he gets
it in all hours of the day prior to JK I
had never seen anyone roast them really
that's why I loved it
the drive through somebody just throw a
cheeseburgers yeah outside of here
Anthony's just like he's the cool he's
the cool guy then when he's in here I
think he kind of likes it a little he's
like getting a whip he's a masochist
yeah you think he's a pain [ __ ] hey Lee
is a pain you have Tick Tock dancers and
then you have kinjas and you have
Anthony so many [ __ ] kitchen members
and I've seen them dance individually
and they're all really good they are
they come together and they're not good
anymore oh what is it aesthetically that
is displeasing when watching hinges too
it's like this thing that makes you like
taste your bile this is how I watch a
little and I can't just video when I'm
at home you know I like the kinjas dudes
I like to click these three little dots
promotes terrorism
oh my god oh Anthony